She is tarnishing every the reputation of every Muslim,
every American Muslim, and they know it now. And they,
I mean, I speak to, uh, I mean, to, uh, in, in the district,
I speak to summaries and I speak to Muslims and they,
the majority agreed that she tarnish their reputation.
People there are not waiting just for handouts.
These are hard workers. The all that they want is to have better lives,
to send their kids to better school, to have a safe district.
So what else are you going to do in Minnesota is fifth district to
supplant Ilhan Omar.
Before that I am planning and I would represent
every,
every voter in this district and not even a voter,
every resident of the fifth district,
because I am running to represent them. Um,
I'm planning to introduce Minneapolis and the
fifth district to DC,
not bring DC to Minneapolis and to that district. Um,
she failed to do anything for them.
And for me, this is, I mean,
she's supposed to be a public servant.
A public servant means that you serve your constituents.
And that's what I'm planning to do. Um,
I will represent every residence of the fifth district,
regardless of color, ethnicity, faith,
and political affiliation.
What do you think the Somali community thinks of her? So.
They are seriously,
they are sick and tired of her scandals of her, uh, uh,
outside influences of her, uh,
narrative that she is tarnishing every,
the reputation of every Muslim, every American Muslim.
And they know it now. And they, I mean, I speak to,
I mean, to the district,
I speak to summaries and I speak to Muslims and they,
the majority agreed that she tarnish their reputation.
People there are not waiting just for handouts.
These are hard workers. The all that they want is to have better lives,
to send their kids to better school, to have a safe district, the.
Same thing as every other American. Exactly.
Exactly. We don't need names. We are all Americans. I don't, when I,
when I travel, when people ask me, Oh, where are you from?
I don't say I'm an American. I am an American period.
And that's the values that I have are the American values.
And the people I love are they Americans. It mean that I hate Iraq.
It's always my that's what I was born.
And these are my extended families.
But when it comes to my heart, my heart is here.
That's why I've been living here for 30 years and I'm not planning to go
anywhere. And that's why I have only one passport, which is the U S bank.
Will you come on stage with me? I have a show in Minneapolis for my book tour.
Tired. I'm going to bring you on stage. We'll we're going to do some stuff.
Change your mind. I'll Sue you.
Well, now it's been recorded. All right, I'll get you the date,
but I'll be in Minneapolis around the May 10th or so separately.
I wouldn't be honored to do so. I would be honored to.
Johann will not be happy with us. I'll invite her too, though.
If she's watching right now, she's welcome to come on stage with both of us.
I've been I've, I've been inviting you for
a cup of coffee forever.
So I think maybe we should have coffee in the neighborhood that you don't live
there anymore because you moved to DC. So I'm in Minneapolis. Where is she?
She's in DC.
Yeah. Can you talk a little bit about some of the other scandals related to her?
Cause there's a, there's a lot of weird stuff out there.
And for the last two years, it was only these very,
I don't want to say very far, right?
It was a seemingly far right outlet,
or I don't even want to say that there were outlets on the right that are
ignored by mainstream that were saying there was this weird thing with her and
her brother and passports and this whole thing. Can you,
can you kind of get me up to speed on what.
I mean, usually I don't speak about it, but it's, um,
I mean,
there are investigations for about so many
things. Like three, four for me, one is many. Yeah. Um,
and especially about the immigration fraud, because apparently based on,
uh, a community leader in,
in the Somali community came out and including,
uh, pictures. And, and let me tell you what happened.
And then hopefully, um,
the investigation would lead to, because she would not never talk about it.
And it's like, Oh, this is so appalling. Yeah. Well she's.
There, she's under investigation right now. Definitely.
Definitely. Yeah. Um,
apparently she had a brother who lived in the
United States and the United Kingdom in London.
And according to her close friends that went on the record saying
that because her brother was gay.
So she decided to bring him to the us being
inside the, within the Somali community.
So maybe he'll get queued. This is the one who, uh,
who defends the LGBT community that she wants
to cure her brother.
By.
Being in this community.
So he came by as a British citizen.
He cannot live here.
So basically they got married and
to give him, well, it's not like for any other reasons. I mean, it's, it's,
it's committing an immigration fraud and that's how he got his citizenship.
Um, she brought him to cure him and basically she used to say,
according to her friends and to the people that went on the record saying that
he's been around the wrong crowd in England.
So it's better for him to come here and be around us. Right.
Okay. So putting aside the part about the gay brother and the curing,
which is bad enough in and of itself,
especially by her own progressive ideals where she's supposed to,
it's supposed to be for gay people, but,
but that's not criminal in and of itself marrying your brother for the purposes
of getting his immigration status is immigration fraud.
And this is under investigation right now.
Do you think it's bizarre the way the mainstream media seems to be covering this
up or is that just sort of congruent with everything else that.
I think we got used to the mainstream media sadly,
but we got used to it.
Have we ever heard anything about anybody about
progressive, about a Democrat? Yeah.
It's always about the us, the conservatives,
the Republicans, it's always about us.
What about all these candles that were around
a large percentage of the Democrats?
It's it, it goes under the radar and they would,
even if they mentioned it,
they would mention it in and in times that are not very popular.
So, um, and then that's it that's.
Well,
instead of the New York times writes a piece about the new hip artist in town,
Hunter Biden, you saw that one in the times, he,
the new hot artist in town, I'm pretty sure Donald Trump Jr.
Wouldn't get the same, uh, coverage, New York times.
Uh, no, not even, not Trump, not his kids,
not his children.
Does it feel in a weird way? So for someone that,
that was a journalist under a dictatorship, um, does that,
or came from a country that was a dictatorship does when you see the way our
media behaves right now.
Similar, similar, exactly,
exactly similar. I mean, having, uh,
uh, they always try to defend all the mainstream media.
They pretend to defend the first amendment,
but what they're doing is so, and tie the first amendment,
freedom of speech is the most important thing.
Uh, there are just doing,
and I know it,
I know what the narrative of the Progressive's and it'll
handle of Rashida, what they bring. I've seen the consequences of,
of the hatred.
I've seen the consequences of oppression and of division.
I run away from it and I was fighting it for 31
years and I am,
as an American citizen would stand against it from NEF.
I was standing against it and I will until the day I die.
Does anything about the machine that you're going up against scare you in any
way? Just, I mean, at the most human level, I mean,
I know you've been through worse in a lot of ways, but it's a big.
Huge machine. Uh,
and especially when it comes to radical Muslims and to the Muslim brotherhood
and to the people behind the Muslim brotherhood faith. No,
if you hear, or if you read that I committed suicide,
I'm not suicidal. I'm very happy.
So look for them because definitely I'm not a,
we've seen suicides here and there, uh,
lately and the, uh,
the Muslim brotherhood is a terrorist group and the first thing would be
my priority when I get elected in November,
that I will make sure the Muslim brotherhood would be
designated as a terrorist group, such as several countries,
Egypt, that's where the Muslim brotherhood, uh,
was formed Egypt, consider it, uh, and,
and other countries in the region consider it a terrorist group.
And we should, we should to, to, uh,
I'm not scaring, not trying to scare people,
but we shouldn't be afraid of name calling things with their real names.
And that's not Islamophobe,
that's not anti anything that's being entitled and reserved an entire
radicalism. And if I don't stand against it,
who else.
Looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics instead of
nonstop yelling, check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.